[Musique]
mais déjà des 4 me diront les secrets de
la vie c'est tout bon camp est astucieux
belle
c'est le plus sérieux des amis nous
invite à jouer comme on dit il ces
filles de vouloir de lui un ami
[Musique]
ba et ba tu es bien rappela t
aujourd'hui
non ça va didot fabrice est ce que tu
veux te joindre à nous ce soir j'ai
invité quelques oiseaux de mes amis à
venir manger du poisson
ah oui oui et des belles sol adacore wii
qui vient à je viens sur le tapis
l'heure actuelle organes et soeurs il ya
les deux petites soeurs aussi qui
viennent à pacy les deux petites soeurs
zone asie sont la wii en bas j'y vais ça
s'est su aller on joue mal foutu on joue
le jeu de la géographie deviner un pays
avec tout d'abord la carte géographique
de ce pays
ensuite son drapeau et aussi la façon
dont on dit bonjour dans la langue du
pays
mais on ne garantit pas la prononciation
non parce que là malheureusement on
n'est pas toujours très doué
voici la carte de ce pays qui comme vous
pouvez le constater est baignée par par
deux mers si je ne me trompe pas si
nathan même bien d'avoir deux mers oui
mais tu sais on n'a toujours qu'une
moment finalement à bord vous ne parlez
pas de ces mêmes de maman je parlais
trop de prix d'avoir deux mers qui borde
son pays fera sua et coûte la capitale
est ici vêtus dans la capitale du pays
elle est haute elle est assez route oui
voici le drapeau du pays
tu peux voir je vais vous indiquer les
couleurs le rouge et en os
le blanc au milieu et le noir est en bas
rouge blanc et noir
enfin comment dit-on bonjour dans la
langue du pays ont dit salam aleikoum
afrique et j'aime l'ange les choses
pareilles c'est y aller et 7 ou encore
les salam alikoum oui pas mal c'est pas
mal comme salam
saleilles moi je leur réponds voilà
salam aleikoum et comme salam alikoum ça
la réponse willy progrès absolument chat
n'est pas laïque août
je ne me lasserai pas combat lui de le
répéter ce pays vous
avait sans doute deviné maintenant
bordée par deux mers oui et l'egypte
avec sa capitale le caire
elle se trouve situé là et que la mer
méditerranée au dessus et la mer rouge
ici sans drapeau et bonjour en arabe se
dire d'egypte salam salam aleikoum salam
alikoum adama dahico soit la maladie
comme ça se prononce à peu près comme ça
et je crois qu'on répond d'ailleurs on
est comme salam joue à gauche alors
salam aleikoum toucan grand ali comme
saddam
oui aller comme ça un peu pourquoi après
un peu près je vais dans le jardin
madame jardin moi je vais retrouver
j'ai retrouvé nos amis oui a donné tout
petit tout comme on est prêt j'arrivais
enfants ne vous impatientez pas je
regarde un petit peu si tout va bien
autour de lui toutes les biens des
listes m tout est tranquille bonbons
fabrice oui si je crois mais oui à bord
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
tu n'as pas piétiner les rosiers une
fois penses-tu je fais toujours très
attention en vacances ce qui fait un peu
n'importe quoi non non non non non je
suis très raisonnables même genre
vacances comme nous ben oui et c'est
bien pourquoi je ne sais pas en vacances
il fait beau oui bah piquant bull qu'est
ce que tu fais là bonjour et pick up
bull
oui les nous fait ce que nous avons à
faire vite rattrapé tout cas encore le
point commun vous êtes un objet une
chose une situation etc
quel est le point que vous avez en
commun
nous allons tous essayés et avec nos
amis de le découvrir là alors je vous
écoute
bon eh bien alors je commence je suis un
objet que les enfants sont très fiers
mais alors très très fier de posséder
les enfants et ailleurs même si retrait
une grande personne ou si c'est un objet
que tout le monde n'a pas le droit de
porter ya pas tout le monde
moi je lui cet objet parce que quand
j'allais en classe à l'école des oiseaux
bien sûr il était très fort en chant
et en gymnastique alors c'est pour ça
qu'on me l'a donné et pour une fois on
devait me la donner mais au dernier
moment on me dit que je l'aurais pas tu
sais pourquoi non parce que j'avais eu
une mauvaise note de conduite face à ça
m'étonne pas ça et alors ça sert et dix
comme on dit rédhibitoire mais
rédhibitoire que c'est compliqué ce
moral alors à moi et bien vous pouvez me
rencontrer en bien des endroits au
sommet de certains édifices
au détour d'un petit chemin campagne
surtout en bretagne on me trouve aussi à
l'intérieur de ces édifices dont je
parlais je peux être au bois en pierre
en métal en ivoire au nord je suis
parfois très simples et parfois très
richement décorées et je n'ai pas
toujours exactement la même forme car
nous avons dans notre grande famille d
origine assez différentes
nous sommes de malte ou de lorraine j'ai
des serres qui sont latine
d'autres égyptienne mais nous avons de
grands points de ressemblance
si votre abri ça commence au tessin où
je suis bon et bien moi je représente
quelque chose qu'on fabrique très
rapidement et vous savez bien que j'aime
tout ce qui est rapide en deux coups de
crayon toc toc
ça y est j'existe et je suis très utile
grâce à - ont par exemple on n'oublie
pas une chose importante
on corrige également une erreur et est
alors j'ai remarqué quelque chose qui
est très présent amusant quand on le
fabrique comme ça sur un tableau noir à
l'école est bien très souvent après
j'entends la même musique et 3 x 3
waka de 12,5 un tat thanh et je crois
pouvoir dire que votre point commun est
une croix du roi des rois il alors à la
croix en effet hébié encore ne crois oui
toi bell bell tu ne crois moi j'ai
cieszyn quoi oui mais non mais tu est
une croix de quoi la solution de croix
de bois croix de fer preah vihear aux
déçus du mic jeu de danse à bruxelles et
puis toi tu es la croix de la
multiplication par là et bien là j'étais
pas la croisée des chemins à mon petit
fabricant fournit des bombes à leur voix
belle belle mais enfin ça va être à nous
maintenant c'est le temps qu'il faut oui
oh oui tu vas nous faire plaisir certain
ah oui ça va être mon chemin et moi mais
tu aimes jouer à ce jeu j'aime bien je
suis fatigué tu sais au mieux nos
maisons sont les vacances en mer rouge
j'aimerais bien me reposer mais non mais
non tu trouves pas changé pas le choix
la semaine prochaine je sais où il est
dur avec moi pousse-pousse charmant moi
j'adore notre petit jeu alors tu vas
bras il supprimer non bon alors allons-y
alors cette fois ci alors c'est un mot
andy les paroles adultes peuvent-ils
être bâché pas beaucoup on susurre
guillette alors on n'avance pas la
première c'est un c bon voila tu te
rends compte que je fasse suis très ami
à 20 2 3 4 puis à 6 tu es toi là tu vois
je la termine par quoi et ben 1 e
voilà bon ben alors est ce que c'est une
fleur bas nous n'aurons pas une fleur
parce que c'est un art non non c'est pas
un arrimage va y arriver c'est un animal
pas trouvé un gros os oui il est assez
gros oui il est impressionnant surtout
ah bon un toucan quand il est très
impressionnant et afrique non oui oui en
afrique
oui oui j'aurais parié afrique il sait
pas howie fait peur il court très vite
oh non non ils ennuient court pas aimé
il va assez vite quand même
arriva est ce que c'est un animal
d'afrique du nord passera plutôt à
l'afrique noire alors oui oh oui plutôt
noir très noir
non non il n'est pas noir c'est
l'afrique que ni les blancs n'ont ils
pas blanc non plus il est vrai d'une
couleur il ya un peu il est oui verve
rta terreuse un peu toi faire été re 1
verte très oui oh oui oui très souvent
les deux mois une autre lettre une autre
lettre et bah écoutes je vais donner la
quatrième oui c'est un c c'est un tu
permets une seconde que je réfléchis je
peux te dire c'est qu'il est très mûr ou
battants je veux réfléchir dit l'être
oui moi j'en ai un qui vient tout de
suite à l'esprit
ah bon mais ça ne va pas ça correspond
pas est ce que tu m'as dit ça ne
m'étonne pas d'ailleurs pourquoi moi je
pense aux crocodiles
et ben oui le crocodile commente unis le
crocodile mais c'est pas un crocodile
comment procéder un crocodile par crocro
dit ah bon enfin alors que manqueront
dit odile moi je croyais bien qu'avec
toutes ses dents live c'était un produit
mais non crocs
on a bon voilà comment on écrit et non
pas auront alors son crocodile ou
vraiment odieux moi je veux bien je veux
bien l'articulent il ya une chose que tu
ne s'est peut-être pas ça y est
contredit les crocodiles comme front de
la coban sait qui ils sont quelquefois
très méchant mais quelquefois aussi sont
très gentils avant par exemple quand ils
dorment dans les rivières
il laisse les petits oiseaux venir leur
nettoyer les dents 1 ils disent rien
c'est bien comme ça tout le monde est
content oui c'est pratique et le
crocodile et n'a pas besoin de se
brosser les dents
et puis les pistes base obama m ils sont
nourris un an mais bon c'est pas bête
oui je vais essayer un jour mais je te
conseille pas tous contents parce que
t'es pas un petit oiseau groupe
qu'est ce qui pourrait me faire est
belle pour être mangés pas peur alors
c'est pas raisonnable c'est pas peur
parce qu'il est loin sinon belle belle
s'il te plaît oui j'étais tort comme
d'habitude la twa fabrice vial jouer
avec moi
là c'est facile la musique du dessin
[Musique]
elle bannit bonjour monsieur ries
dis-moi oui je suis extrêmement
aujourd'hui paresseux bon alors c'est
moi qui comme un non tu expliques tout
moi je ne veux rien faire je veux me
détendre et bien je remplace les mots
enfin dans les mots les syllabes qui
sont des notes de musique je les
remplace pas ou bien blue ou bien et moi
qu'est ce qu'un cheveu t'as rien alors
c'est une idée assez originale
moi j'avais tout mon nom même si tu
trouves comme d'habitude d'abord je
remets les notes sur la portée ou à
l'arrivée sont d'accord
alors il fallait que j'explique tous mes
cours ou pour à leur écoute moi temps
une grande responsabilité dans la sphère
aujourd'hui c'est un lourd phare un
lourd fardeau sur tv pour les gt
garantie que si nous parvenons à toi et
moi et effectuer cette pointe ce sera un
véritable galles ray galles ça doute pas
un seul instant de ton talent je dirais
même des taux génie mon petit fabricant
oui tianjin mais c'est que je te demande
aujourd'hui c'est une attention soutenue
qui ne doit jamais dit muet d'intensité
diminuer dit mis la note me à la fin de
cette épreuve qui verra sans doute notre
triomphe
je me propose de décerner un diplôme oui
tu pourras te considérer comme lauréat
de la deûle de récré hâter la faculté
qu'elle a fait mais je n'ose y penser
nous n'arrivions pas à nos fins tu ne
peux pas savoir je sentais bien la balle
mais toi tu es aux balles et vêtu
m'empêche du dieu ce que j'ai a dit m
alors tu as compris rien du tout le noir
mais bien logés côte monique dumont
romain de malabo non
mais ce serait pour moi on dérive des
plots illusion tu ne m'écoutes pas aussi
tendre manque d'habitude mais si ma
petite bulle belle désillusion alors à
mettre le 6 voilà chers fabrice j'aime
gagner
j'ai le plaisir de thanos et puisque tu
as été très froid très investi hier
quand même passé pas alors il n'y a pas
beaucoup de dossiers à dolisie jamais
terminée et regarde les notes se sont
toutes les notes de la gamme et dans
l'ordre dos alors j'aurais dû maintenant
passer tu veux oui on va le mettre ici
et voilà do ré mi fa sol
non c'est dans ses parts dans lions et
mais voilà il manquait lé sol à des
peines
je ne sais pas j'étais distrait par
rapido celui qui m'a empêché l atelier
chant d'oreilles fa sol la si do où elle
a aimé on va chanter toutes les notes
cette fois dans notre petite musique est
ok
[Musique]
et 4 ça n'est déjà pas mal d'amis les
quatre ça lit vous diront qu'il ferait
que la vie majed j'ai changé des choses
mais comme juni pas de mine war il
faudra faire attention les gars ça ni
sont contents quand ils sont réunis les
coop ça me rend heureux car il aime la
vie
oui
[Musique]
vous invite à jouer
aujourd'hui il suffit de vouloir devenir
ami dj jeu vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]